you're a very talented musician you play
the piano very well thank you for saying
I love to play piano we're playing a gig
tonight and that rock well if anybody's
here you're invited okay right well
every when I'm not working in in town we
do have a residency at Rockwell didn't
los feliz 8:30 to 11:00 yeah would you
say that your musical nods because your
wife Emily very beautiful gorgeous
you've how long you been married five
we've been together about five and a
half years married since November 8th
you know two years ago okay very good
you got to get that right and though my
question is you would you say that your
musical talents helped you meet her help
reel her in so does I don't know about
that that but what did happen is that
she was dancing I saw the first day we
met at the gym she was dancing that
night someplace doing aerial she does
she was in the in the Olympics she does
the rhythmic gymnastics and Cirque de
Soleil kind of thing she was doing stuff
where they're like twirling on the
ceiling holding on to a yes she just did
the body doubling for Emma Stone in
la-la-land oh my god and they do that
aerial dance in front of the performance
of her perform the forensics here okay
because you are a man you are fast you
met her at the gym
yeah and that night you go see her
perform yeah okay because you were in
for the kill right well I liked her
right away yeah and and yeah we
exchanged numbers and she said I'm
performing tonight so I yeah I drove
over I hope that meant you drove yeah I
didn't know so I rizky Tovar
and then two days later she came to the
gig and I said hey do you want to do
some of your acrobatic contortion on my
grand piano she said absolutely wait a
minute so you were gonna play the piano
and you said I want you to do your
acrobatic contortions you fiend
this is very early in a relationship for
you to be seeing her contort herself on
your piano the muttering like Popeye in
the old cartoon oh that's great
the yes sir she came she came to the gig
and we played she said yes I'm gonna do
it so she got on the piano I quickly
quickly cleared things off because she
just did it
higgledy-piggledy like that Hegel deep
Ngozi and he whispered the moments for
the moment bring back the old phrases
sure so so and I said give the gang what
should we play let's play making whoopee
we just we'd seen that one of my
favorite movies is that you know
Michelle Pfeiffer on the piano when she
does that Fabulous Baker boys yes yes
anyway we played that and sure enough
she did it yeah it was good okay well
look that's I was just amazed this guy
man I was amazed just how confident you
were you met her at the gym immediately
you're watching her do contortions at
her show and then you're saying come to
my show and then you have the gall to
play let's make whoopee it's very sexual
song yeah fantastic and it's all worked
out so well you have so far one child 18
month old Charlie mm-hmm is it home mmm
sweet sweet as a shoofly pie
sweet issue bye-bye I must get home
penalty to see Wow okay and we have
another on the way like you if all goes
well April 8th will be our and your
bought your wait a min April 8th I'm the
18 how did you know yeah I know many
things about you well you do now yeah
you've seen it all more of a copper
anyway
you